[Music]
to the berkshires national space
organizations supported by NASA in every
state as well as Washington DC and
Puerto Rico States math programs very
going to the needs of individual states
but the overriding purpose of statesman
is to encourage students to participate
in space related research and pursue
space related careers to assist teachers
in producing space related material into
their curriculum and to inform the
public about space related activities
that your message uses for example we -
my fellowship support for dozens of
students every year mainly to
participate in summer programs at NASA
centers as well as in space
at their own home institutions together
with the Museum of Science
every fall we put on Massachusetts space
they were hundreds of high school
students get to hear about the research
done by universities to create a
Distinguished Lecture to address the
public every CEOs administrators and
directors astronauts and NASA chief
scientists but never before a NASA
Administrator as we have today Mike
Griffin took over the leadership a year
ago is the fact that dr. Griffin does
back to the moon and beyond recreating
the capabilities that we once had back
in the time of Apollo but which we
allowed to disappear now most of you
students who were here weren't even
alive during the Apollo program it's
ancient history it's a heroic age but I
know from speaking with a lot of you
that the idea that you students can now
once again take part personally in the
human exploration of the solar system
has spread incredible excitement through
your ranks
remember though this time we want the
exploration to be sustainable so that we
don't just go to the moon a few times
and stop but use it as a stepping off
place to the rest of the solar system
and we have to do it with a relatively
constant budget not with the crash
program that was Apollo and while we're
recreating this capability we have to
bring the shuttle back to
late status and operate it safely for
another five years while we're
completing the construction of the
International Space Station and
hopefully service the Hubble Space
Telescope one last time and we have to
do our best to maintain the science
program that have won NASA worldwide
admiration well by any standards this is
a tall order maybe it's trying to put 10
gallons into a 5 gallon can but mike has
accepted this challenge with
determination and with humility he
certainly is uniquely qualified to lead
NASA into this new era with experience
in government industry the military and
academia he's a true rocket scientists
and knows the space business like few
others he's brought about major changes
in NASA in just the one year that he's
been at the helm and will watch with
great interest the continued evolution
of the agency Mike I know you give lots
of talks to many different audiences but
I doubt if you'll meet up with an
audience containing as many absolute
space nuts as we have here today we're
impressed by the magnitude of the task
ahead and we wish you success in meeting
these challenges MIT shares a very long
and proud history of cooperation with
NASA and we look forward to working with
you to make the vision for Space
Exploration a reality we're delighted
that you've been able to come to speak
with us today and we look forward to
hearing what you have to say ladies and
gentlemen let's welcome the NASA
Administrator Mike Griffin
thanks Jeff raise your hand in the back
if you can hear me somebody great thanks
worthwhile to check that now and then
Jeff what what time do we need to be
done by so we're good okay great
I just didn't sure I just didn't want to
rush if everyone had to be out or good
thanks for the introduction that's way
better than I deserve by a whole lot I
only have so much distinguishing us to
go in me and I have to save most of it
for Congress so you all only get a
little bit of any distinguished 'no snow
that i might have to go around i wanted
to talk with you all today about our
exploration architecture how we intend
to return to the moon how it fits as we
fast forward to go to mars a little bit
maybe in QA about why it is what it is i
could almost say I'm here with NASA so
read my view graphs but I'm not going to
read them to you I'm going to talk about
what's important about each one because
they're gonna be on your website and
you're gonna have those to read more
carefully yourselves and I've always
hated presentations where somebody sat
and read to view graphs to me so with
that let's step forward why are we doing
this as I've had occasion to remark a
couple of times today to some students
who have asked the question you know is
all about the vision for Space
Exploration comes about sadly in the
wake of the loss of our second space
shuttle Columbia in flight and the
realization on the part of the Columbia
accident investigation board that what
we do in Space Flight is expensive
difficult and dangerous but that is also
strategic for the United States in many
different ways and we should not cease
but if we're going to do it the goals of
the enterprise have to be worthy
the costs the risks the difficulty we
need loftier goals in how gaymans words
and that flying the shuttle to the space
station can at most be a step along the
way it is not V goal as it had been for
the last 30 years and more in the
American space program most of that and
and in fact much more was captured in
Chapter nine of the Columbia accident
investigation boards report I think we
are as a nation indebted to Admiral
Gehman and the people who assisted him
in going beyond the proximate cause of
the loss of the orbiter and and getting
to deeper issues I think without that I
would not be standing here today because
the president listened the his
assistance in the administration
listened and they crafted a far-reaching
policy for for NASA that goes beyond the
shuttle and the station and what we were
doing today or in any given
administration after the kind of
discussion and debate that you would
expect and I was privileged to be a part
of that debate as a someone outside NASA
and therefore an expert witness once I
joined NASA my IQ went way down and I'm
no longer considered in an expert but
while I was outside NASA I was
privileged to be part of that debate and
after a year or two of discussion this
vision for space exploration for NASA
and the civil space program was adopted
by the Congress and in fact hugely
ratified it was adopted unanimously in
the final passage of the 2005 Space Act
authorization for NASA in which it is
declared substantively that the goals of
the u.s. space program are as you see
them here we will finish the Space
Station we will use the shuttle to do so
we will retire the shuttle in 2010 we
will develop a replacement capability to
put humans in orbit and and beyond as
well as as cargo that will substantially
replace the capabilities of the
spaceship
but in a in a different way we'll return
to the moon no later than 2020 and we
will work to extend human presence
across the solar system in concert we
will implement a sustained and
affordable balance between human and
robotic program and we will use all this
to promote international and commercial
participation why do we do it for me
there are many reasons some of them are
captured here on this slide the
principal ones are captured but I will
say that that for me though it's one and
two are the most important the human
curiosity that leads to the desire to
explore is quite literally wired into
our DNA all of us here in North America
or in the Americas are the descendants
of people who chose to leave their homes
and come here in fact all of us who
aren't living in Africa are the
descendants of people who chose to come
come somewhere else
it is wired into us and when humans
could only master the land that's what
we did when we learned to master the sea
that's what we did the 20th century was
about the conquest of the air it will be
a while before we can say that we have
conquered space if we ever do so but it
is something that makes us what we are
we can't afford to spend our a
significant portion of our national
treasure on it but we spend some and I
think we should we spend seven tenths of
a percent of our budget on it 15 cents
for the average person for every day
I've said this several times because it
usually gets at least a chuckle but I
spend more than that on chewing gum and
every time I hit a golf ball into a lake
I use up my month of NASA's budget so we
don't spend a lot on space exploration
but it is not an expenditure that we
should do without the second reason of
course is that well I am an American I'm
proud to be one I think that our nation
is and should be and should continue to
be a leader among
I think the more opportunities that we
have to partner with other nations to
create allies rather than adversaries
make our nation make the human species
stronger and better space exploration
affords us an opportunity for benign
cooperative American leadership on a
basis that I believe given our stature
in the world should be and should
continue to be a first among equals but
recognizing that we do have equals but
that this is something we want to do and
want to do together I think it
strengthens our nation strengthens our
society strengthens the species and it's
if there were no other value that we got
from space exploration other than the
cooperative benefits from working with
other nations in the world I believe it
would justify itself on those merits
alone that's a personal belief but it is
mine why are we going back to the moon I
get asked that question at nearly every
venue which I pop up and so I'll just
preemptively answer it we want to go to
Mars and beyond we've been to the moon
so why are we going back well first of
all yes people have been to the moon for
a cumulative time of one man month on a
landmass the size of Africa I don't
think that we can claim to have explored
the moon I personally find the moon to
be an interesting place from a from a
scientific perspective and especially
from an engineering perspective in terms
of what we will learn to do with it in
learning how to fly in space and live in
space and work off planet a long time
ago I believe it was craft Araki one of
the painting Monday pioneers who said
that if God had wanted us and meant one
in man to explore space he would have
given us a moon
he was tongue-in-cheek he knew we had a
moon so I think it is important to use
that moon both for what may be there
that we don't know about for what is
there that we do know about and for what
we can learn about living off planet
before we extend our reach further as I
said earlier today and have said in
other venues but
we can go to Mars we need to learn how
to assemble a space station size payload
four or five hundred metric tons in
low-earth orbit without taking 15 years
to do it we need to do it in a few
months and before we can go to Mars we
need to know how to seal a crew inside a
submarine tell them to push off and not
show their heads again for two and a
half years we can't do that today not
with any certainty that they in fact
will come back alive and until we can do
it we aren't ready to go to Mars we will
learn to do it by voyaging to the moon
and living on the moon and again the
moon is is interesting of itself there
are fundamental issues of astronomy
physics astrobiology historical geology
which we may be able to settle in
utilizing the moon what we've proposed
is as an architecture and this was a
discussion about our space architecture
what we've proposed is an architecture
that with as little fuss and bother as
possible and making use to the maximum
extent that we could do it possibly the
the things that we already owned and
creating the fewest new things does the
following it meets our human spaceflight
goals it offers us a reasonably
significant advance over Apollo in terms
of crew time on the moon for the money
it is sized to operate read with
reasonable efficiency at two lunar
missions per year six months apart sort
of like a space station crew rotation
cycle but of course could do more it
leaves behind a hundred and twenty five
metric ton launch capacity for going to
Mars and you'll appreciate that if I
need four or five hundred tons to go to
Mars that's four or five launches of
this vehicle even allowing for some tare
weight as opposed to how many dozen
space shuttle and Soyuz and progress
launches to build the space station a
much better approach this is a much
safer system the probabilities of of
loss of crew are cited there
it does meet our agreed-upon
international obligations for servicing
the space station provides an orderly
transition of the shuttle workforce and
and allow and can be bought by the yard
allows us pardon me
allows go as you pay budget planning
lunar surface activities offer us an
early demonstration of human exploration
beyond low Earth orbit we learn how to
operate away from the earth but only
three days from home I think no one will
be surprised to if I say that there are
things about living off planet that we
don't yet know despite having had six
voyages to the moon 35 years ago I
believe we should keep our hubris in
check recognizing that we need to learn
a few things
we certainly conduct can conduct
numerous scientific investigations with
the moon as a natural laboratory one of
the most important things in developing
a more efficient spaceflight
architecture will be learning to in
quotes live off the land in space or on
the planets and asteroids that we visit
in places the lunar crust is as much as
40% oxygen by weight it's at least 15
percent by weight most everywhere that
we've sampled and the oxygen is
available for human huse by heating it
up we need to learn how to do that in an
automated fashion because oxygen is is
seven-eighths by weight of the most
efficient chemical propulsion
combination we're going to be using for
a while
liquid oxygen and liquid hydrogen so if
you can and and voyaging to and from the
moon the mass fraction required for for
propellant is about 50% so a 50% of your
mass and space is propellant and 7/8 of
that is liquid oxygen that you can get
from the moon rather than hauling it up
from the surface of the earth I would
suggest that one of the earliest
economic returns from utilizing the moon
would be to generate and ship liquid
oxygen it's going to be a while before
we learn how to do it but I think we
will and of course we begin to establish
a
an Antarctic style outpost one mission
at a time and in also testing of the
techniques and technologies that we're
going to need to go to Mars and pass
that now in contrast to Apollo we are
planning an architecture that offers
global access because to to scientists
and engineers both the polar regions of
the moon offers some of the most
interesting sites whereas Apollo as you
can see from this chart was restricted
to the near equatorial band the far side
of course is also of interest one of the
more interesting places is near the
lunar South Pole on the far side and the
Aitken basin where within close
proximity to one another there are sites
for possible lunar bases that are that
have access to twenty four-hour-a-day
well full full time sunlight as well as
two permanently shadowed shadowed
craters there's evidence from a lunar
prospector in Clementine of elevated
quantities of hydrogen and if we can
find both hydrogen and oxygen on the
moon then that will be the germ of a
truly valuable space economy we won't
find it out without going there and so
some of our early plans are focused on
the Aitken Basin and shackles and crater
we will also need many different things
besides merely the transportation to get
to the moon power systems communications
Rovers habitat laboratory modules I'll
talk a little bit about those in a
moment in the context of international
and commercial opportunities let me
review the flight plan with you I think
maybe many of you here who do have an
interest in space and if anybody does
it's MIT students and faculty 33 of your
compatriots have have been nasa
astronauts including my host today a
good portion of you may be looking at
the hardware that one day some of you
will fly
so the flight plan starts with a
heavy-lift launch that allows us to take
the earth departure stage and the lander
into low-earth orbit we're utilizing a
combined earth orbit rendezvous and
lunar orbit rendezvous scheme for a
variety of reasons it seemed to us - to
come out ahead and the architectural
studies that we did and following the
heavy lifter if that gets tore but
safely we would launch the crew crew
docks departs from Earth orbit flies to
the moon deploys into low Earth orbit
leaves the crew exploration behind with
without crew in at this time and lands
on the moon once on the moon you do what
you're gonna do eventually come home
rendezvous dock return return to earth
nothing magic here and not much that you
didn't see in Apollo one thing as I say
in every venue in which I give this
demonstration the the the heavy lifter
and the crew launch vehicle and the crew
exploration vehicle or our probably
pretty solid if you look at those you'll
see the designs we'll be flying in just
a few years as I commented earlier to my
old friend Ed Crawley don't don't fall
in love with the lunar lander in fact
don't even do any heavy dating because
what the lunar lander is at this point
is a weight allocation and we are you
know we don't want to commit too early
to what the systems designed for the
lander ought to be and in fact I think
ed and some of his students are taking a
look at that as one independent body for
us but the CEV while not very elegant
offered a number of advantages to us
first of all that we we ended up
deciding on the apollo shape the outer
mould lines we have an extensive aero
database on that the five and a half
meters there has has since been
downsized to 5 meters to make it fit
within the actually there were several
issues one was the the weight margin
that we wanted to have with the launch
vehicle another was when if we have to
do a launch abort the 5 and
F meter base diameter gave us a fairly
large projected area which produced a
fair amount of aerodynamic drag and
getting off the launch vehicle and in
order to reduce that to tolerable levels
that we could deal with with an escape
rocket we we shrunk it from five to five
and a half to five meters but it still
offers a quite significant increase in
volume from Apollo we can carry six
people to low-earth orbit per the terms
of NASA's Authorization Act so we can
service the space station as required we
can carry four to the moon as part of a
larger mission this can serve as the
vehicle to get the crew up and back at
the start or end of a Mars mission it
offers us the flexibility the service we
expect to have a design in which the
service module can fly by itself with
unpressurized cargo or operated in a
space tug capacity we are putting
forward a system that we think has a
pretty good amount of flexibility to do
what we need to do with getting people
and medium cargo up and down from space
for the next several decades
and when I say several decades I think
all of you here appreciate that
aerospace systems generally from dc-3s
and b-52s to Soyuz and and space
shuttles and and things like that
expendable launch vehicles tend to have
a very long operational lifetime decades
they're expensive to design expensive to
build expensive to keep up and we don't
change them rapidly so the designs you
see for crew and cargo heavy-lift are
are going to be the designs that will
take us to Mars oops pardon me one of
our requirements is that the CEV must be
capable of servicing the space station
which was one of the things that fell
out of our mixed lunar orbit rendezvous
and Earth orbit rendezvous scheme with
that scheme of course the first step in
any mission to the moon the first step
is the launch of the heavy cargo
provided that goes well we then launch
the crew but the crucial thing is we
stage throughout through lure low-earth
orbit
while if we're staging through Lu
low-earth or
the crew exploration vehicle can go to
the space station or it can dock with
the with the heavy lifter in the lunar
cargo how does it know the difference
like the old joke about the thermos
bottle right keeps hot stuff hot cold
stuff cold how does it know the
difference the CEV is basically a
vehicle designed to fly from the surface
of the earth into low Earth orbit or
into cislunar space that's what it does
and whether it goes to the station or
goes to the moon is a matter of large
largely indifferent matter to the to the
design so we can meet our obligations in
that vein at no real additional in fact
we were not able to find any significant
requirements to serve the space station
that were not there in terms of going to
the moon much like Apollo Apollo service
3 Skylab missions because if a vehicle
which could fly to the moon could also
fly to the Skylab the launch systems of
course as a real key to the
transportation they are of two stripes a
125 metric ton heavy lifter and a 25
metric ton crew lifter by the way the
heavy lifter is man rated and if one
only wanted to go to an equatorial
region for a particular reason
then the heavy lifter alone with the CEV
on top could get you there but if you
want to go to the polar regions you need
you need more lifting capacity it will
not be lost upon you that these vehicles
are derived from shuttle systems the use
of the shuttle solid rocket booster and
external tanks is clear so there are two
new elements in our architecture an
upper stage for the crew launch vehicle
and a CEV we will be doing things like
extending the length of the external
tank and and quite possibly extending
the length of the solid rocket boosters
but fundamentally they are systems we've
already paid almost all of the
non-recurring engineering development
cost in order to create and we're trying
to make use of them as we go forward
I've basically said most of the points
on these charts
third bullet down says that we're
building a new locks hydrogen upper
stage and it says that we are going to
use a space shuttle main engine and
that's up and we might use a space
shuttle main engine we might use the
Apollo era j2 LOX hydrogen in because
the shuttle main engine requires
development to do an air start and is a
little big for the burnout thrust so
we're we're considering a couple
possibilities there but the payload
capacities are in the range that that
are indicated for the heavy lift cargo
vehicle we'll add a segment onto the
solid rocket boosters by the way the
five segment solid rocket booster has in
fact already been tested the heavy
lifter as such can put a hundred and six
metric tons to low Earth orbit by itself
and if you add the earth departure stage
for the lunar capability then you can
put 125 metric tons in low-earth orbit
of which 55 metric tons can go to the
moon and of course it's built out of the
same man rated components as we're using
today so it can be used for crew if you
want earth departure stage is the moral
equivalent of the Saturn s4b
upper stage third stage used in the
Apollo era a little bigger takes the
Apollo era model could carry right
around 50 metric tons to the moon which
was that was the translunar injection
mass on apollo 17 this will do about 55
metric tons so we pick up a little bit
the extra is very nice to have I think
I've already said everything on this on
this chart lunar lander will deliver in
their initial sizing for crew to the
surface I have no doubt that more could
be packed in if one wished does offer
global access we are sizing the whole
thing to be able to land 20 month 21
metric tons dry weight okay net of fuel
to get down
and and that says I commented earlier
don't fall in love with the
configuration the real thing you want to
know is that the architecture will let
you land 20 plus metric tons we want to
figure out the lander design that
utilizes that in the maximally efficient
way early on we're planning on for an
ascent in a descent stage and so we want
the ascent stage to be as small as
possible because it truly must be thrown
away whereas the descent stage will be
left behind and should be designed or
designed a bull in such a way is to
offer a lot of leave behind in terms of
building up a lunar base because we're
never going to find any resources on the
moon more valuable than the the tanks
and the metal and the electronics that
we take down with us in the descent
stage ok so we are thinking about those
things in the slightly longer run we
want the lunar lander ascent and descent
stage to be one stage and to be reusable
because we want to park it either on the
surface or in low lunar orbit and refuel
it either from in situ resources
developed on the moon or from fuel that
is shipped out from earth but we don't
need to bring a lander every time we
should think about bringing fuel if we
have to bring anything so we're not
ready to commit yet to the design of the
lander but this is one concept earlier
on in the bottom bullet we were thinking
about LOX methane for the ascent stage
propulsion because there's good transfer
ability of that to the Mars ascent stage
because Bob Zubrin and others have
investigated the utility of extracting
methane propellant from the Martian
atmosphere in a catalytic reaction that
uses only a little bit of hydrogen and
that's a neat thing and we may well do
it there are also other in-situ resource
extraction possibilities for Mars so I
don't think we're ready to commit to LOX
methane but in any case we were planning
on using it for the essence stage of the
lunar vehicle and and removed it from
consideration because early on the
development cost was going to be quite
high and when we looked at it it didn't
offer any payload advantage for the moon
and doing something now for Mars that
doesn't offer a payload advance
for the moon didn't didn't seem to be a
fiscally appropriate thing to do so we
we will drop back to another propellant
combination
maybe Lux ethanol possibly hypergolic s'
for from art for a lunar ascent there
are a number of commercial opportunities
and we want to add veil ourselves
everywhere we can of the option of
purchasing services and goods on a
commercial arm's length transaction
basis it is in that fashion that we
might have some opportunity to help
create a true space economy rather than
having everything we do be the result of
a government prime contract we intend to
purchase launch services and
communications services as soon as
they're available and in fact I think
all of you know that we have allotted we
have allocated I hope the Congress
sustains we've allocated a half billion
dollars over the next five years to help
serve as seed money for entrepreneurial
or even larger firms who choose to
invest in creating a truly commercial
cargo and crew carrying capability to be
able to service the space station the
space station logistics market is a
market that we are willing to and in
fact eager to turn over to industry
because we we believe that it is
incontrovertibly true that if something
can be done by industry at all it can be
done cheaper than having the government
do it most estimates would say at least
a factor of five or six times cheaper
and we'd like to be able to take
advantage of that so we're trying to
help bring it about but as we move
forward to the moon
there are Rovers to be built power
supplies to be emplaced
communications systems to be orbited
around the moon navigation systems to be
put in place there are a lot of services
and goods that we believe we can
contract with industry to a supply on an
arm's-length basis and where they might
be able to sell residual services to
to other enterprises we hope that can
come about similarly there are many
opportunities some of the same
opportunities for international
cooperation where other nations can
elect to participate with us in going to
the moon so that in exchange for a seat
in the lunar lander you know maybe maybe
they help to and build an in place a
habitat maybe they help to provide
communications or a rover or power
supplies or an automated cargo Lander or
or or or we have tried within NASA to
offer an architecture that does a couple
of things first of all it does the
minimum necessary to meet the
presidential e stated and
congressionally approved objectives it
does not do more I think we do not want
to return to the day where NASA was
going to just do everything we designed
an architecture which has which does
what we are told to do does not do more
but leaves an awful lot of places a lot
of interfaces a lot of hooks and scars
where either other nations or commercial
enterprises can join in to make it grow
from a slender read to a branching tree
the architecture however that we've
advanced does the crucial thing that
only in this era only the government can
do and only the United States government
can do and that is provide robust we
believe safe and reliable transportation
for a significant number of people to
low-earth orbit and then take them on to
the moon that is the crucial step with
with which we believe an international
program can be forged and without which
nothing can happen and and we believe
that in this era only the United States
can do it and so that's the part that
NASA will do this is a chart for budget
geeks that says our plan fits within at
least in in the near term fits within
the budget profile we've been told to
expect
this is the chart that sort of my semi
get off the stage chart but captures
what I started out by saying and this is
a couple of quotes from me that that
again my will people abstracted from
speeches I gave and put into the
presentation so I'll let you read them
later and this is a quote from Gene
Cernan which I I think is hard to read
without a certain sense of humility I
believe that great nations do indeed do
great and ambitious things and that this
is something that the United States must
do to be a great nation and a great
society in the 21st century and beyond
and that's why I took the job thank you
for your time and attention I'm yours
for questions and for 50 minutes
according to schedule
[Applause]
we have a microphone here which we can
pass around so everybody will be able to
hear the questions so start raising your
hand and yes is it on yeah so um thank
thank you very much this is very good
I'm with the math works in Natick
Massachusetts and of course I have a
question about the design process I read
somewhere that you are taking a
different approach to design and the
traditional spiral based approach you
want to have a much more direct approach
to designing the systems that will
eventually take us back to the moon
could you elaborate on that a little bit
how you how you think to achieve that in
particular just a contrasted if you look
at the Joint Strike Fighter program they
took a deliberately spiral based
approach and you chose another is there
a particular reason for that so I guess
there's two questions well other than
the fact that the GAO published a report
saying that the Joint Strike Fighter was
overweight underpowered
short leg and and couldn't carry much
weaponry that's just the kind of program
I want to emulate a spiral development
is a term that to my knowledge and I
might well be wrong originated in the
software world where one does a
continual iteration between capabilities
and requirements to to grow them ever
greater and has been used in the
acquisition world and and the buzzword
may have gone in the other direction for
all I really know and it's been used in
the DoD acquisition world you know I
think that's a fine approach when you're
talking about production systems or
systems that you're designing to go into
production where you'll have a lot of
units a lot of users and expect to have
a long term evolution of requirements I
would like to get to a point in the
space business where we have enough
demand and are producing enough units
with enough different and growing
requirements to be able to say that I
thought I
development acquisition approach would
be useful
it was my judgment that the space
business for the next couple of decades
will not be that type of business and it
was frankly my judgment that we would be
lucky to get one spiral that what we
should do is build a system that will
meet the stated objectives in the
simplest and most direct manner possible
using as much as possible the Heritage
from components which had already been
developed and paid for and if we
absolutely had no other choice develop
some new thing a very very much of a
there's a Japanese phrase the the nail
that sticks out is hammered down that I
learned from my roommate in in college a
million years ago
and there are times when you know you
want to take a bold new step and times
when maybe you don't want to attract
quite so much attention to yourself we
are trying to Reeve Ector the human
space flight program of the United
States from one which has been focused
on low-earth orbit for the last thirty
years to to going to the moon and beyond
and I chose not to put any developmental
yeah I've got enough political hurdles
and enough mental hurdles in changing
the paradigm of what we do with civil
spaceflight in this nation I did not
want to have developmental hurdles now
I've spent years doing one new thing
after another I would love nothing more
than new developmental challenges I
can't resist at heart being a system
engineer it's what I was born to do but
I restrained myself because we have
other problems right now so that's why
it looks the way it looks miss in the
front row the red whatever I don't know
if I was a sweater or skirt or a blouse
I can't see that well from back here has
NASA been considering low-level
developments of that list or Delta not
as a primary CEV carrier but as a backup
to the shuttle derived two inch to
assure human access to space well the
five meter diameter of the sea
allows it to fit nicely on an ee LV an
expendable launch vehicle the Atlas or
the Delta just from a fit point of view
the out of the EE L V's would have to
grow a bit to accommodate a fully fueled
CV their capability to the orbits that
we need to go to is in the neighborhood
of 20 metric tons or less I don't know
that we can get a CV down that low let
me let me just remind everybody who ooh
that the Apollo system carrying only
three people to the moon was a 30 metric
tonne vehicle right on the nose
technology has moved on structures have
gotten lighter Electronics doesn't waste
so much da-da-da-dah all right but
getting a fully fueled and loaded CEV
down to a weight that the eeo v can
carry probably something we can't do so
the EE LV is gonna maybe have to add
another e in front of it for evolved
evolved expendable watch vehicle before
it could be really useful for us they
may very well do that and some of the
hardest things to change are things like
our that there would be conceptually the
simplest like the base diameter so our
vehicle envelope is compatible with
theirs but at present there's not a
direct utility of the EE LV family for
for a crew launch backup not to say that
there could not be and and we're open to
that possibility later on there are some
other issues there the EE LVS don't
offer a very robust abort strategy the
the trajectories that they fly are
rather lofted for efficiency if I were
and I used to do designing trajectories
I would want a more lofted trajectory
also but then that makes a very high G
load in getting off the vehicle at
certain points in flight and we really
would rather not kill crew if we could
avoid it and sometimes launch vehicles
will fail in fact one in 50 times or so
launch vehicles will fail so you have to
assume that they will fail and you have
to have a robust abort the EE LV in its
present form would not provide that EE
Ovie's today are not man rate
I mean the Air Force would be the first
to tell you that why should they man
rate them we would have to spend a good
amount of money
- man rate the vehicles and the air
force is not going to do that for free
if we man rate the vehicles we either
have to have two production lines which
there isn't a sane production engineer
in the world who wants to do or
everybody is going to have to buy a man
rated vehicle even for an unmanned
launch which of course addresses the DoD
requirements they will not be real fond
of paying the extra bill required to buy
you know copies of a man rated launch
vehicle because because we needed it to
be man rated so as a backup or emergency
capability sure I'd like to reach a
state where one day we could do that I
really would but as a thing that you do
routinely there are considerably there
are sound reasons of programmatics and
and fiscal policy that would argue to
keep those lines separate and that was
the argument that we made in crafting
this architecture and it was believe me
fully accepted because people you know
below the top line do kind of understand
that that there are these differences
and then after we got it all done and
got approval for this architecture some
of the senior ranking Air Force guys to
me and said you know thanks thanks a lot
you know we really don't want you
messing around in our production line
you'd be stupid to use the EE L V and so
we said okay now we may very well use it
for cargo deployment in fact I would
hope to but as a crew carrier it's not
I'm not saying it can't work and if you
spend money on it you can make it work I
mean you can make anything work but as
it is today it's not not that well
suited I answer your question okay
there's an awful lot of stuff that goes
into these engineering trades you know
it's just really annoying in the back
is wonderful commendable and expensive
as is the International Space Station as
is the Space Shuttle and I'm happy to
give you my thirty cents instead of
fifteen cents to pay for this but most
of the nation is not and so you have
been moving forward with this with in
somewhat of a static budget meaning
there concomitant reductions in other of
NASA's operations and I'm wondering what
are the painful cuts that you need to
approve in order just do this within a
static budget and in particular the ones
about the earth monitoring well ours
monitoring as a NOAA responsibility not
a NASA responsibility we helped develop
the technology but but we don't we don't
pay for the earth monitoring systems by
and large unless their research
activities and and their a science
program is something I'm happy to say
where I have restored budget since
returning to NASA rather than taking it
away and and you can look at the record
on that your your statement is obviously
pejorative and so but I will try not to
address it in that manner the money that
we're spending on NASA probably will not
go up and probably will not go
substantially down because there are
political objectives and and and goals
that go well above my head that would
act to keep it from going up
substantially or down substantially and
the science program at NASA is valued
for itself and will not go substantially
up or substantially down I would argue
that the next actually the highest
priority would be to restore some help
to aeronautics but the Aeronautics
budget is not currently as robust as I
would like to be like it to be entirely
apart from any considerations of space
exploration but having to do with other
policy objectives so the net of that
statement is that we spend a certain
amount of money on human space flight in
the country and probably will continue
to do so because the NASA top-line and
constant dollars isn't going to get
a lot and neither is the science portion
so the vision for Space Exploration is
largely about what do we do with the
money we spend on human spaceflight I
and many others believe it is strategic
and that it is important to the United
States to do it
some many disagree I fully understand
that but the argument is that if we are
going to spend this money on human
spaceflight then exploring space beyond
low-earth orbit is a more productive
more strategic more important use of the
money than is remaining in Earth orbit
and and being confined to the space
station I I must disagree with your
assertion that that seemed to me to say
that that most people did not support
these objectives I actually was a little
bit surprised but the Gallup folks ran a
poll in December that I thought was
unusually well worded they got beyond
the usual rather course policy sampling
that yields a rather on a rather
ambiguous answer and they phrased the
question in the following way given that
the budget force for NASA remains less
than 1% of the federal budget and
currently we're at 7 tenths of a percent
given that it remains at less than 1% do
you strongly support support are
indifferent about or mildly against or
strongly against and then they list up
the goals of the vision for exploration
return to the moon go to Mars all that
75% of the population either supported
or strongly supported those goals given
the precondition and actually it's about
77% I'm rounding down and the spectrum
of approval was gender indifferent and
political party indifferent to within
you know the accuracy of the sampling so
when people understand most people I
would offer from informal sampling that
when I just talked to casual observers
most people believe that the space
program uses an amount of money somewhat
comparable to DoD it's it's amazing how
will you talk to people
they'll say you know what do you think
we get at NASA and they sell you know
what half what DoD gets and I tell them
4% and they're stunned I tell them that
we spend less than 1% of the budget on
NASA and they think it's pocket change
it's not an issue for them so given that
the amount of money being spent is not
an issue the issue then becomes what do
you think the productive use of that
money is and I believe or I would not
have taken this job that the proposed
effort is a more sensible use of the
money than other efforts upon which we
have been engaged and and that's the
best answer that I can give you as to
what we're doing and why were you're
doing it in the middle you were the
first one I'm sorry for you
the future also do you regard these
groups more elaboration staff only if
only because I'm getting to an age where
I can no longer remember really long
questions I hope we can get shorter
questions in the future but I think the
essence of your question was you know
how do we regard what do I think of and
how do i regard commercial enterprises
and you know with the the precondition
that their more innovative yes they are
and I'm desperately hoping that they
succeed which is why I've advocated and
am advocating for a half billion dollar
allocation of NASA money to help seed
those enterprises in the next few years
by and large the innovative commercial
enterprises that have been offered up so
far I made this comment earlier in
visiting with some of the students are
mostly pretty view graphs and loudmouths
which is fine any good idea actually is
going to start with that and the
question remains as to which of the
entrepreneurs can turn pretty view
graphs into pretty hardware I hope at
least a couple do and we are trying to
provide that seat money I recognize that
NASA has a reputation in the past of
trying to stifle commercial initiatives
as if they were competitors that is
wrong and wrongheaded it is against the
policy of the US government since the
Eisenhower years to allow government to
compete with what can be offered
commercially in my view when you use the
term exploring space to refer to putting
humans in orbit you may be accurate but
that's unfortunate exploring putting a
human into orbit was explore
space when John Glenn did it the first
time if we had conducted our space
program properly and and properly
involved industry as early as we could
rather than as late as we could
putting people into space would be a
routine activity that companies could do
without our help and without our
involvement and we could merely buy
tickets which is not to say that the
government wouldn't have its own systems
I mean the government finds it
advantageous to buy to buy me a ticket
on United Airlines to come up here and
the government finds it advantageous to
mean maintain military airlift
capability to move it's it's folks
around and and they manage to co-exist
quite successfully so I believe being at
either end of the spectrum is wrong and
we've been operating in NASA as a
strictly government enterprise for
moving people and things around for for
far too long so I'm doing everything I
can to sponsor the development of truly
commercial capability over the next few
years now it's a chicken and egg thing I
said I'm putting half a billion in it
why don't I put more in some of the
entrepreneurs want me to put in more
starting with the presumption that any
money we spend and the government is
wasted if we would only give it to them
we would get good value well guess what
the taxpayers are not fond of betting
large amounts of money the Congress will
not approve speculating with large
amounts of money on a gamble that a
supplier may or may not show up we have
a space station to sustain we want to
return to the moon we have to conduct
our affairs in such a way that when we
spend money we definitely get a product
I can't fail to accomplish the stated
mission because I I bet on an
entrepreneur who might or might not be
there
so I'm treading a fine line between not
doing anything to help the entrepreneurs
and risking the non accomplishment of my
stated mission because I trusted
entrepreneurs who turned out not to be
there it's a difficult difficult path to
walk and I'm trying to walk it because
I'm convicted of good if the government
can't provide some seed funding and
frankly some seed demand that we won't
be able to leverage this economy for
example I cannot looking back
historically I
cannot imagine the development of the
American West without the
government-sponsored transcontinental
railroads okay I cannot imagine that
that would have happened we would have
always been we would not have developed
the West with wagon trains and mountain
men you know the development of the
American West began in the last third of
the 19th century after the railroads
were there so there is a role for
government in helping to cede private
enterprise and I'm I'm you know I'm on
to do that desperately and frankly
looking for ideas so I hope some of
these folks that you mentioned can get
to the next stage Beyond view graves
[Music]
but in our ongoing projects and so my
question is does NASA envision
reestablishing any blending in
eventually yes but let me pose to you
the following dilemma oh I'm sorry the
question was her life science research
has been cut and what do I plan to do
about it well I mean that's the net of
the question sorry and the answer is
right now nothing because I'm
responsible for trying to complete the
space station according to a
long-standing and highly interlocking
set of international agreements that we
have I think appropriately chosen to say
we will we will honor I'm trying to fly
out the shuttle and retire in 2010 I'm
trying to build a new system have NASA
build through its prime contractors a
new system to replace the shuttles
capabilities trying to keep the overall
space science program as intact as I can
and not further hurt Aeronautics life
science research for NASA is not the
only life science research in the nation
nation by any means in fact we're not
even the primary user life science
research at NASA has the the sole
purpose of trying to figure out what's
going to happen to human beings when we
put them in space well I don't have any
interest in finding out what happens to
human beings when I put them in space if
I can't put them in space and so and I'm
not being cavalier about that although
it sounds that way it's just because I
get the question a lot so I have a
limited budget a lot of requirements on
the plate and a necessity of making some
very hard choices which involve cutting
some things I would very much like to do
because I think the priority order has
to be to restore for the United States a
set of capabilities that we once had
that we allowed to atrophy that we now
wish we had not allowed to atrophy and
that we must recreate and I need more
money than I've got to do that and so
unfortunately for the next four or five
years most of the research activities
you have come to know and love from NASA
are going to be reduced now we had
proposed some cuts in research and
analysis in our purely space science
budget which would would not help this
lady and and we may actually decide to
cut a mission and restore some of the
RNA money because I'm very aware of the
frustration among the scientists at
losing you know graduate student support
and things like that I've been a
graduate student we may rethink that we
can do that but broadly speaking I just
don't see an opportunity for much life
science research within NASA for the
next five or six years I just am out of
money that's I wish I could give you a
better answer on the left I haven't had
any attention over there
what airlock decision do you refer to
okay the I mean even high-level
requirements can always be scrubbed as
I've pointed out several times the lunar
lander is not designed yet but in our
thinking is yes the requirement for an
airlock for the following reasons if
people are going to go to the moon and
stay for more than three days if they're
going to stay for a week or weeks at a
time which the system is capable of
supporting of course need to have a
relatively habitable environment in
which to live lunar dust is the more we
study it the more harmful we understand
that it is it's it's basically finally
blasted rock which is quite sharp and
and we think quite toxic to humans so we
don't want lunar dust cluttering up the
actual habitation space
I've phrased this inappropriately we
want as little lunar dust as possible
cluttering up the habitation space if we
drag suited crewmembers into an area of
the lander or any of the other lunar
habitat things then we will inevitably
have a huge amount of depth and it will
be problematic now if you knew that you
were only going to use the lunar lander
tool and never and get out of it and not
get back in it until you were coming
back home or coming up to orbit for a
rendezvous and definitely had another
habitation module then you wouldn't need
the lunar lock in the lander and you
could put it in the ham module I'm
trying to look out 15 or more years in
the future and guess whether there's
enough money in the program to guarantee
that I'll have a lander plus a habitat
and I can't guarantee that at least I
don't think I can and so it's a little
bit of a suspenders in belt approach if
I've got to live out of the lander for a
while then I
airlock that's the thinking I'm not I
don't you know I don't think
Moses with a set of stone tablets that I
carried down from the Mount I look in my
closet every day to see if those tablets
are there telling me what to do and they
weren't there this morning so you know
some of a lot of this is is human
judgment but yeah I'm I'm the guy that
said there's got to be an airlock
because there was a lot of dispute about
that on our team so I at some point
somebody's got to make a decision so I
said there shall be an airlock and those
are the reasons why I mean sometimes it
comes to that I you know the the
toughest decisions are the you know 55
percent 45 percent kind of decisions and
and nothing ever comes to the boss that
that's easy or somebody else would have
done it so that was the thinking way in
the back on the left
a smaller vehicle and
yes on the grounds of obviousness that's
not a good strategy for a couple of
reasons
the first of which is that any payload
that goes to the moon is fifty percent
of it is propellant and a large fraction
of that is hydrogen and it might well be
that the most difficult technology of
spaceflight in our era is preventing
liquid hydrogen from boiling off
I forget the rates but it's significant
so that if you intend to leave a liquid
hydrogen powered stage in orbit for any
length of time like like weeks and
months many percent of the propellant
load will boil off now we can argue how
many percent many percent is and how
much effort I can go to to thermally
isolate the payload but it's a difficult
problem if I'm going to assemble a lunar
payload of of say 50 or so metric tons
which is it's kind of hard to do it for
much less than that unless I can shrink
people in eeo V for example using that
payload capacity to get all the stuff up
that we needed in low Earth orbit or on
the way to the moon the minimum anybody
was able to come up with was a scheme
that you know had at least half a dozen
EEO v-class launches so then I you know
I mean I used to be in this business you
go down and talk to the guys who launch
atlases and deltas and you know they
might get off one a month if it was
really pushed and who else is going to
be able to do a lot better so it now
takes six months to assemble a payload
to go to the moon of which you know the
liquid hydrogen is sitting there boiling
off and the pieces and parts don't join
together well the whole logistics
strategy for I don't you know I don't
think we'd get permission to go if we
needed six launches minimum or more for
every time we wanted to head for the
moon moreover if I need that many
launches every time I want to go
or more whether the standard version had
nine and if you think I have a 98%
probability of success on any given
launch multiply 90 point nine eight to
the ninth and you probably won't like
the reliability number so if any one of
those launches fails I've now lost the
whole mission right and I'm not even
talking about crew fatality I'm just
talking about an important piece of the
overall mission assembly didn't go so
for reasons of logistics for reasons of
packaging for reasons of fuel propellant
tank technology and for reasons of
reliability we decided that it was best
to have fewer launches if I had pieces
and parts that it could all be done
easily in one big launch and still give
us the kind of capability we need we
might have done that but that was the
answer and and we I'm giving you verbal
arguments but we reduced all that to
numbers and oh by the way it was hugely
cheaper not to do half a dozen or eight
or nine launches it was hugely cheaper
so we subjected it to the most rigorous
analysis we couldn't it wasn't even a
close call over there
now I'm sorry over on the side of the
room has had his hand up for a while
well maybe but again back to
chicken-and-egg not in the next four or
five years because there is no
commercial capability so in if I enable
it now then in four or five years it
might be there in which case if it is it
will hugely reduce our logistics cost to
Space Station and I will be able to put
that money back in other things that's
why I'm investing now
no other there look there's a couple of
government 101 things here that you need
to understand so that you don't ask
questions like that again government
agencies are not allowed to make up
their own missions I can't I don't want
to but I even it might but my feelings
about it are irrelevant
I can't either de saw I can't decide on
my own either to acquire or shed
missions other agencies can't decide
that they will accept a mission
requirement that I give them the the
charters of the different federal
agencies are enshrined in legislation
there is a 1958 Space Act azzam as
amended that created and charters NASA
to do certain things charters the DoD
you know all the agencies are like that
I don't get to just decide what my
charter ought to be such decisions are
not accompanied without an enormous
amount of Groening and screening
screaming throughout all of government
if if they need to be adjusted I can't
imagine a policy environment in which
somebody in which just having decided
within the last couple of years what
NASA's purpose was going to be for the
next 20-some years okay and having just
been approved by the Congress if
somebody says all by the way now we
think we'd be better if some other
agency handled the earth to orbit
transportation problem it's just just
some politics is is the art of the the
possible this is just not something
which is even possible okay now if I can
get a successful commercial investment
going then I can use NASA dollars to
procure commercial services but an anti
will absolutely well but I cannot
offload that on some other agency
there's just just not just not there all
the way in the back
George Lucas was offered five to ten
million dollars to the winner of a
certain debate with you or anybody and
as the debate Richard Hoagland in either
he's a bomb or his ideas are threatened
just decide one way or the other they're
together be done with it
who is Richard Hoagland
oh I'm sorry I yeah I'm not going to
address that there is no face on Mars
it's it's a land formation stop I mean
stop me or I'll shoot in the back oh
yeah sorry selection process like I've
got a hundred and forty some astronauts
I think I hope I got the count right and
something like 70 of them haven't flown
[Applause]
take care of yourself and stay in good
physical shape for the next crew
selection and and we've got we've got 16
shuttle flights plus one for Hubble and
and and there's only so many rookies we
can carry on each flight and it's fairly
obvious that we won't even fly be able
to fly all the folks we've got which is
very regrettable I mean you know I I
just those are those are the mathematics
so no I don't think we're gonna be
selecting any more astronauts for a
little while I'm sorry center there
because just because you're under the
light and I can see you well I see it
coming back when I have money to pay for
it the Prometheus program prometheus
program was scoped out at 11 billion
dollars and that was before any hardware
had been cut there's just not 11 billion
dollars in I mean maybe there's some
parallel quantum universe according to
the many worlds theory in which there is
11 billion dollars for NASA to spend in
this era on electric propulsion but it
isn't the universe I'm inhabiting it
just that just is not going to happen
yeah electric propulsion if we developed
it would be really neat it's a great way
to move cargo around I would love to
have money for space nuclear thermal
propulsion and for space nuclear power
which would feed into the electric
propulsion I would just love to have
money for all that stuff don't have it
I think NASA is in a place where we have
the we have the money we're going to get
we have to demonstrate that we can do
some neat things with that money
things that are strategically important
to the United States and which excite
the public and we have to do those
things well and this has got to occupy
us for the next half dozen to a dozen
years and when we do that
when we demonstrate once again that we
can execute missions with skill and
cunning and daring and innovation and
and and be reliable in doing what we say
we can do then maybe people will listen
to us when we say we would like to go
beyond but we we have we have some
things to prove back back there well
sure
the reason why the lunar architecture
looks the way it does is that the Earth
orbit rendezvous sequence we have is a
little piece in a big piece well the big
piece is big enough that within four or
five launches spaced out over you know
off to launch pads 39 a and B that are
probably going to be with us for a while
within a few months we could put
together a Mars payload launched in 125
you know one hundred hundred metric ton
chunks that's about the size of a
payload that you need to go to Mars if
you've studied the problem at all I'm
sure you've come out with that same
conclusion because everyone else who's
ever looked at it has said it's about
one space station mass equivalent to go
to Mars and I don't think we want to
spend 15 years doing it so the lunar
architecture looks the way it does in
order to provide a heavy lift or leave
behind the CEV looks the way it does
because it's a vehicle which among
certain other choices but it is one
choice which can bring a crew back from
Mars return velocities fundamental
purpose of the CEV is to get the crew
you know the first hundred miles up in
the last hundred miles back going to
Mars we will live in a habitation module
of some kind maybe derive from what we
do on Space Station
maybe not but we will clearly need more
than just the CEV and the heavy lifter
but we will need those and they look the
way they do in large parts so that what
we're doing for the moon can transfer
over to Mars now not with any thought
that what we're doing for the moon is
everything that we need for Mars far
from it but that at least what we
develop to go to the moon should be
useful
going to Mars in the orange shirt I've
said many times but only because I
believe it that the International
Cooperation the pattern of international
cooperation that we've gotten out of the
Space Station program will be its most
lasting legacy because the hardware will
eventually come down but we have forged
over the last 20 years partnerships with
with Europe Japan Russia in very
difficult circumstances in many cases
and those partnerships have hung
together through exigencies that that I
would have predicted and in fact did
predict would would destroy the
partnership so I was wrong they've held
together quite well I had a heads of
agencies meeting last week the
partnership is solid and strong we hope
to take it with us to the moon we hope
to add partner nations and we certainly
hope to take it with us to Mars
thanks for your economic analysis our
the part of CEV which is reusable or
might be reusable is the command module
and it is indeed an interesting question
as to whether it ought to be reusable or
not the reason why I've asked that it be
reusable is that if I don't ask the
question I can guarantee that I will
only get one answer and that is that it
should be expendable and the contractors
would love nothing more than to build a
new one for me each time in point of
fact the Apollo command module was
reusable we just didn't reuse it I mean
it could have even been reused on a
lunar mission without replacing the heat
shield we used the heat shield was so
over designed but we didn't plan to do
it and and didn't so the question I'm
asking our team is why essentially why
can't it be reusable and if you want to
reuse it how would you design it to make
itself and if the answer comes out to be
prohibitive we won't do it it's really
an economic question our cost modeling
people who I've known for a long time
and truly believed to be the best in the
world indicate that if we can get four
or five reuses out of a command module
we get over the knee and the curve for
you know the the non-recurring
engineering to make it to make that
statement come true and if we get ten
reuses out of it we we we really make
money like a bandit so we're not trying
for you know the shuttle will fly a
hundred flights kind of reuse we're
trying for five or ten and if it doesn't
make sense we won't do it since you
already seem to know the answer maybe
you can just phone up my cost model guys
and tell them and I can get them working
on other stuff but all joking aside
we're trying to take an unbiased look at
it and see reusability is obviously not
a technical issue it is obviously doable
the question is what does it cost to do
it and does that cost pay for itself
don't know yet sir
well I don't know I will try the
Russians have been superb partners they
have done what they said they would do
in a period of great difficulty for the
United States and for the international
partnership in Space Station as a whole
I believe that as the space to when the
space station gets assembled we will all
use it we will find ample use for it but
I believe then that the partner nations
will want something new to do and I
believe that Russia will want to be a
part of that we can't hold a gun to
their head and make them but I believe
that Russia will want to be a partner
with us as one now of three nations in
the world with with their own
spacefaring capability in terms of human
spaceflight I would like to have them on
board and and there will there will be
places for them but but they but they
need to be volunteers not draftees I
mean I can't make them do it so
ultimately it will be up to the Russian
President and the Russian Duma so how's
your fate you sure a couple more
questions yes ma'am
the president has already extended an
invitation to India to invite closer
space cooperation with the United States
on his visit last week and I'm looking
forward to that relationships with China
are as you know sometimes difficult we I
look at the space program as a way to
make those relationships easier and I
hope that a a way can be found to
encourage such cooperation right now
such cooperation in space with China
hinges on larger issues in involving
defense and human rights and you know
trade and and other things that go well
above NASA and so I really just can't
comment on that at the present in the
back from entrepreneurs and companies
what do you need from us turn out great
students I'm not being flipped
universities exist first and foremost in
my mind and I've been to enough of them
exist to educate I was telling
mentioning to a student earlier who
asked that question I said you know
you're equipping yourselves as students
not not as you professors are equipping
the students with the tools that you're
going to be using for a 40-year career
you know build those tools well because
you never gonna get as much opportunity
to learn and grow as you have here at
the University so that's the first thing
the second thing of course is that I
mean I would be hard-put to think of
anything that we do at NASA whether it's
robotic science missions or you know
space architectures or in many cases
very specific subsystems and instruments
where universities and university
laboratories are not involved I mean the
Draper lab grew out oh and the Lincoln
lab grew out of such interactions I came
back to NASA from Johns Hopkins
University's Applied Physics Laboratory
I worked at the Jet Propulsion lab you
know they're operated by
you know other great institutions Johns
Hopkins and Caltech you know the the
space enterprise involves universities
at every level one of the things that I
hope we do and maybe the most important
thing really is to be doing the kinds of
things in space that makes students want
to do difficult stuff in order to be
part of it that may be our greatest
value sir
well the decision of what we do at the
moon versus when we transition to Mars
will will be made by future
administrators and future congresses and
future presidents I've tried to craft
and to supervise the crafting of an
architecture that allows but does not
require someone to develop a lunar base
and that allows but does not require a
transition to Mars based on the CEV and
the heavy lifter and again we need some
additional stuff to go to Mars there
there is not a technical need for and
there is not a budget of budgetary
possibility of beginning work on a Mars
architecture today first things first
we're trying to finish the station fly
out the shuttle build rebuild a
capability to get back to the moon
now next year but when I walked into
NASA we were 15 months late as far as
the Congress and the White House muted
of putting forth an architecture for how
we would merely return to the moon and
how we would replace the shuttle and my
overseers were not reluctant to let me
know that so in the last 11 months we've
put together an architecture which
everybody seems to find acceptable not
elegant but acceptable for replacing
shuttle crew and and lift capabilities
for getting people back to the moon for
sustaining the space station for showing
a path to Mars so this year we're gonna
talk about with our international
partners and next year what we're gonna
do on the moon and who we're going to do
it with and then as that begins to get
firmed up we're going to talk about how
we will use these pieces and parts and
partners to get to Mars I think it would
be you know one of my favorite movies is
John Wayne's True Grit where these guys
are squaring off against each other on
opposite sides of a clearing and one of
them insults the other and they say
that's bold talk for a one-eyed fat man
I think it would be bold talk for a
one-eyed thin man if I were to start
prescribing the in gross detail the
architecture and timing and transition
from lunar based activities
Mars based activities when the 2020s are
about the earliest we can see that
coming true
I'm just hoping to be you know above
ground in the 2020s so it's not that we
don't care it's that I think it's a
little premature okay I think we're done
I think that last it's on the dream of
going to Mars will get us all excited to
go home because there's probably Martian
blood flowing in all our veins that's
that's what we all dream about Mike it's
been great having you here thanks so
much thank you